et
c'est une île peuplée de navigateurs et
d'amoureux de la mer le joyau de
charlevoix paradis crise vacanciers
cycliste avec ses paysages de cartes
postales et ses 23 km de route côtière
une île forte de son histoire
fière de ses traditions
et parmi ces traditions la partie de
croquet au bout de l'île à l'ombre de
l'église de saint louis je mets aussi un
prétexte pour se rencontrer échanger et
en période électorale on parle politique
c'est le gouvernement la note de passage
moi je pense que oui il ya peut-être
possible donc s'arrêter un autre et à
leurs trophées du coup je ré
l'environnement une priorité
c'est toujours l'argent qui mène tout un
peu partout ben à l'environnement et à
la santé c'est des choses importantes
selon
une autre particularité de l'isle aux
coudres c'est que ces habitats ensemble
au diapason de l'ensemble des électeurs
québécois depuis plusieurs scrutins
c'est ce que l'on pourrait appeler une
ville baromètre leurs intentions de vote
pourrait donc donner une bonne
indication du résultat de la prochaine
élection
et le sujet dont tout le monde parle ici
c'est le service de traversier pas
toujours fiables source de bien des
inquiétudes
ça c'est le bateau rentrera ça qu'on a
eu tout l'été christian du four le maire
de lille est un ancien capitaine ancien
directeur de la traverse pour lui c'est
la priorité absolue car tout le reste en
découle l'économie le tourisme et c'est
vital pour nous là on peut pas seulement
un bateau le king ou des bateaux qui
sont fiables pour pouvoir sur une peur
notre pérennité le pin up service à
chênois d pour le maire le lien parfois
difficiles avec le continent c'est clair
nuit au développement toutes nos veines
il part puis s'en vont ailleurs l'otan
faut travailler pour améliorer notre
sort a apporté des jeunes familles qui
veulent venir s'installer la campagne
qui débute est donc ici l'occasion de
faire passer des messages même si
personne ne se fait d'illusion on n'est
pas une grosse population
mais quand on voit mais on peut dire que
on apprend une grosse puissance le
pourvoi des
pour les touristes un arrêt à la
cidrerie de lille est un incontournable
les clients donc ne manquent pas mais le
propriétaire éric gagné est confronté à
un autre problème comme le reste du
québec une pénurie de med le défi pour
nous c'est non nos travailleurs ce que
je vais le mettre ailleurs le soutien
qui vient de travailler seulement l'été
melo il part à cause des cégeps qui
partent à la mi-août donc ça c'est pour
nous c'est mortel l'isle aux coudres à
voter massivement pour la cac en 2018 et
comme beaucoup ici l'homme d'affaires
est prêt à faire confiance à nouveau à
françois legault avec moi mais ma note
globale au gouvernement est bonne très
bonne je n'ai pas de souci avec ça mais
on vote prévient-il n'est pas un chèque
en blanc à quand les gens de l'île
promettent ils exécutent puis le canton
se fait promettre des choses que ça se
réalise pas ça nous agace simple c'est
une première chez nous
la boulangerie bouchard est un autre
endroit très fréquenté pendant le mois
d'été sa terrasse devient le centre du
village en cette journée c'est une
institution sur l'île depuis trois
quarts de siècle mais la campagne qui
débute ne suscite pas beaucoup de
passion ici peut-être parce que son
issue ne semble pas faire l'objet d'un
consensus au moment où on se parle si on
regarde toutes les parties en place
qu'y voit-on pour prendre la place de
monsieur lebon qui voit-on c'est donc
sans grand enthousiasme que noël ange
harvey qui a voté je me demande pourquoi
qu'on a des élections c'est beaucoup
d'argent qui va être donnée pour avoir à
peu près la même situation une
impression d'impuissance largement
partagé ici au delà du résultat du vote
que beaucoup pensent prévisible c'est
donc peut être aussi dans leur état
d'esprit que les 10dans de l'isle aux
coudres sont représentatifs de
l'ensemble des québécois alors que la
désaffection vis-à-vis de l'élection
pourrait rimer avec abstention
[Musique]
et